today we're gonna do a character
examination but also have a little
discussion around rock log who is the
first black character to appear in my
ear academia the second one being his
infant son who I assume is called ROC
locked I mean look at him he's basically
a clone now this video was actually a
subscriber request so if you have an
idea for a video please leave it down
below
okay so rock lock is a pro hero in his
30s and we actually currently don't know
where he places on the hero rankings but
what we do know is that he has a pretty
interesting quirk called lockdown now
pay attention to this description
because it's it's a mouthful with this
power he can fix any nonliving object to
a specific point in space just by
touching it as a basic example that I
just made up if he threw a ball at him
he could catch it and then leave it
suspended in the air where he caught it
so the thing is that he locks down are
pretty difficult to move but they can be
moved if you apply like excessive force
furthermore his super move which is
called deadbolt allows him to not just
secure a specific object in space but
rather it allows him to secure an entire
area in space which is pretty useful if
the environment around you is collapsing
or shaking so the drawback of this quirk
is that there is a limit on the size of
objects he can lock down and the fact
that his lock can eventually be
overridden with enough force I feel like
if the lock was unmovable it would be
actually a really really good quirk like
if the things he touched couldn't be
moved by anyone except him but as it
stands is quite limited despite being
pretty cool
also I forgot to mention that he has
these little protrusions coming out of
his fingers and they resemble keys which
kind of plays into his character design
and I got to say in the manga at least
this is one of the most stylish hero
outfits that exists period now whilst
rock lock is a person to make quick
judgments based on first impressions he
will freely admit when he's been proven
wrong and perhaps due to the fact that
he is a father of a young child he was
the character who was most resistant to
the idea of having students tag along
for dangerous missions in fact he can
initially come across as quite
judgmental but in reality it's just his
way of showing concern now in the manga
we've seen that rock lock is incredibly
confident in himself so much so that he
actually arcs and I tired to use his
quirk on him because rock rock believed
he could change the future and if you
want to know more about nite ize quirk
and how we can predict the future then
the link is in the description for that
video which i put out last week also
final thing i actually forgot to mention
this but his real name is Ken okay so
now we've reached the end of the ROC
clock explanation part of the video so
now we're gonna move on to the wider
discussion around his character but
first I'm gonna set out what I think and
I advise that you listen till the very
end because if you were to only listen
halfway I think it would probably skew
your interpretation of my opinion so to
begin
unlike completely fictional locations
like Hogwarts for example where there
are no black people for no discernible
reason my hero academia is set in Japan
by and large is generally generally not
a place you would find by people now
that being said whilst my fear academia
is set on earth it's not our earth it's
not our world that we live in is set in
the far far future meaning that there is
a sufficient gap in time between where
we currently live the world we live in
and where the story of my hair Academy
takes place that gap in time is so
significant that you can use it to
justify any change you want really and
this is another important thing it's not
to say that you should do that either
it's not to say that you should make
demographic changes to include more
people in your show I'm simply saying
that up until seasons 1 2 3 there have
been no black characters whatsoever the
justification that people will make for
that is that black people don't really
live in Japan today and that is true but
I don't believe that argument has any
weight because the world of my here
academia it's a world set in the far
future that just happens just happens to
slightly resemble our present and that's
only because as I think deku said the
manifestation of quirks prevented
humanity from evolving for a while and
to be a hundred percent clear the fact
that we haven't seen any black
characters up until this point hasn't
prevented my enjoyment of my hear'
academia but when you do character
analysis like myself you do just notice
things for example like if I look at my
thumbnails it kind of hits you that yeah
overall I love overall Mario I love
Miriah I love all these characters but
yes they are all of the same demographic
bar none so what I'm trying to say I
guess to wrap it up is Rock lock does
matter because having a character who
resin
with a large group of people who watch
this show it's only gonna benefit the
show and it's only gonna help to
convince more people to get on board
with the greatness that is my ear
academia and I would welcome more
characters who look like rock look
because at the end of the day horikoshi
can do whatever he wants and just to
reiterate I'm not saying that this is
taken away from my enjoyment of the show
I'm simply saying that rock lock is an
important character and it's good to
have at least one hopefully we can now
build on this for the future there's no
harm in it like I said it can be easily
justified but that's just my take on it
I really want to know what you guys
think should my hero academia have more
characters from different demographics
and that's not just black people that's
all types of people or do you think that
it should try and stay close to what
present-day Japan looks like and just
out of curiosity if that is your opinion
that they should stay true to what
present-day Japan looks like what do you
think of characters like principal naisu
and ashido and you know a fukayami or
Takayama sorry people who obviously
clearly don't represent current-day
Japan's demographics because they are
like they're mutants so what do you
think of characters like that but that's
all from me guys we've done rock lock
explained and we've done a little
discussion around why he is important
yeah thank you guys for watching and
there should be a video next week and
shout out to everyone who retweeted my
last video the names or torii their
twitter handles should be on the screen
right now
you